onde estão as listas telefônicas páginas
amarelas as locadoras de vídeo
as empresas de compras e de quem é que
vai ligar a cooperativa de táxi pra
pegar um táxi quando acaba o evento está
no mundo em muito a gente vai passar o
dia aqui falando sobre transformação
modelos executivos e tudo está
acontecendo no mundo
mas o fato é que quando a gente olha
para a educação
mesmo com todos esses devices com tudo
que está à nossa disposição educação é
muito parecida o que é
centenas de anos atrás e por que a
educação evoluiu nesses exemplos que eu
dei um exemplo simples mas que
aconteceram nos últimos dez anos porque
a educação nos últimos dez anos
nos últimos 100 anos não mudou a gente
mais ou menos sabe o que fazer
há muito tempo né a o diálogo socrático
data de 2400 anos 400 anos antes de
cristo
a gente já tinha é um embrião do flip
quest tron da aprendizagem ativa de
alguma forma o modelo de de modelo
pedagógico reflete o momento político
a gente teve na idade média uma
regressão e onde passou por uma agente
voltou para o modelo ou não aí né de
professor fala nós copiamos é uma foto
do século 13 doutrinador que de alguma
forma é é durou muito tempo
hoje a gente vem falando em tentar
quebrar esse ciclo que é um ciclo ficou
muito forte mas aí alguma maneira está
dado um pouco como educação é feita no
mundo algo está muito forte e que se
falou de habilidades de vida
a educação aliás a educação brasileira
tem um grande problema que é o final do
ciclo básico acabar numa prova que é o
enem ou vestibular no caso isso força
essas escolas serem conteudista o que
tem se feito para mitigar um pouco esse
problema de ser conteudista é
caso tais habilidades de vida no
currículo a gente sabe porém que música
e artes aumenta o número de ligações
inativas é das crianças todo mundo tá
diz que tem filho tá preocupado com isso
mas nos dá em países onde a gente não
tinha um modelo que é medido por uma
prova no final né e já já tinham já tem
implantar uma educação muito mais aberto
caso estados unidos por exemplo arte e
música e outras atividades de
criatividade estão muito presentes no
currículo mas não é bem isso entra no
ensino superior
a gente vê um movimento de idade de vida
que ele sabe que a pessoa precisa ter
algo não é vocação de oratória
escutatória e outros esqueça as sementes
e na vida
mas mesmo com as habilidades de vida ele
não pode dizer que está transformando a
educação né até porque outros países já
aplica se o software usa chips kills com
muita intensidade
então por que a educação não muda o que
está acontecendo com a educação
eu vou elencar seis motivos para a
inércia do sistema educativo em geral o
primeiro deles é um modelo que os alunos
gostam é como assistir televisão neo
cento lá é professor dá aula legal vai
ficar assistindo os professores estão
acomodados que aprenderam assim tenta
replicar aquele modelo do jeito que quis
aprender e pelo gestor é ótimo é barato
coloca a sala de aula um pincel o
professor e pronto acabou a história é
também nessa grande e dá resultado de
alguma forma
então por que mexer nesse modelo que é
um modelo simples que agrada os três têm
rodgers eu vou mexer nisso
um segundo motivo é que as empresas de
tecnologia educacional ditec é muitas
delas são feitas são informadas por
jovens brilhantes começam que a idéias
fantásticas
eu leio muito isso e digo pra vocês
dessa uma grande maioria desconectada da
pedagogia
isso é um grande problema de você não
consegue usar essa tecnologia em sala de
aula além disso o modelo de modelo
tarifário como modelo por aluno sp custa
muito caro e quando vai para um grupo
maior educacional tem integração com os
sistemas robustos rp e aí começa a falar
com o então integrar um monte de se ter
minha né um monte com o sistema o que eu
tenho a minha
grande como é que eu faço isso
o terceiro motivo há aqui não existe
incentivo e escolas de ponta para
implantar a nova tecnologia
você coloca um professor top prêmio
nobel na sala de aula com um monte aluno
que aprende sozinho né autodidata pega o
livro aprendi sozinho os alunos e as
dúvidas só ao alcance do professor
consegue andar até o aluno vai lá tira
dúvida acabou problema com o incentivo
de uma substituição de ponta que
trabalha com professores e alunos de
ponta para inovar e mudar esse modelo
que funciona a gente tem as fábricas de
diploma então na outra ponta
eu vendo do diploma pelo menor preço
por que que eu vou aí do caso você tem
um caso um aluno que ele precisa de um
papel para conseguir uma promoção do
emprego dele conseguir um cargo na
prefeitura o que quer que seja
e se tem do outro lado as obrigações que
não tem necessidade de gerar valor
agregado a isso diz ganho de escala e
ter menor preço possível pra essa
educação aí também não se existe um
incentivo para transformação uma
barreira grande que a gente enfrenta no
ensino superior é a parte regulatória
ter uma idéia a gente hoje aqui no
brasil eu vou falar de brasil
a gente não pode ter medo grafia digital
como bibliografia básica nos cursos de
educação superior até hoje ter mt minha
pessoa escolhe o capítulo a luva na
xerox que achar a pessoa compra o livro
vai vai na véspera da prova falta livro
que faz escola tem 20 livros não têm 100
livros 500 livros como tenho de alguns
tive esse sistema por questão
regulatória jogadores são muito
conservadores não deixa a gente mudar
isso aí imagina eu gravei digital
disponível para todo mundo ao mesmo
tempo hora que você quiser se na
distância a prova tem que ser feita tem
que ter apoio de pólos presenciais e à
distância no brasil por exemplo
então a regulação na trave após a outros
vários exemplos de como a regulação
trava a inovação ea transformação no
ensino
agora vem um outro ponto que talvez seja
o mais importante de todos que é o ciclo
da educação
você hoje pode uma escola sem barreiras
nessa em sala de aula sem currículo
gente de diferentes idades diferentes
modelos mas o fato é o seguinte vai
demorar a 20 e 30 anos pra você ter
certeza se você conseguir ser modelo
funcionou não funcionou
o ciclo é muito grande então você fazer
uma opção por uma escola instituição
alternativa
significa muito risco do pai de que está
escolhendo o próprio aluno está
escolhendo isso alguns pais têm ousadia
e assumir esse risco né mas a grande
maioria prefere o caminho que já é
consagrado e conhecido há mais um
exemplo da finlândia na finlândia
destaque no pisa pessoal finlândia tem
cinco milhões e meio de habitantes se
implantar o comunismo na finlândia dá
certo
é é é os países nórdicos 55 países
nórdicos têm 26 milhões e meio de
habitantes da grande são paulo em 21
milhões de habitantes
então não dá pra usar o exemplo da
finlândia destaca e pisa matemática país
pequeno desenvolvido uma base cultural é
diferenciada como exemplo de
benchmarking de transformação pedagógica
e educacional a mais a coréia do sul e
coréia do sul se transformou em locação
verdade 1954 fim da coréia fim da guerra
da coreia
japoneses foi embora porque não tinha
universidade fez a opção pela inclusão
cri universidades
em 2010 a escola base matemática e sabe
o final da história
mas a história da coreia no estado de
inclusão uma história de gestão
educacional não está necessariamente e
metodologia de inovação e de fazer a
coisa diferente do que foi feito até
hoje
eu só vou acreditar que a gente criou um
modelo de subjetivo de educação a gente
tem um modelo transformador da educação
onde se implantar esse modelo na nigéria
para citar um exemplo exemplo num país
que está em desenvolvimento na áfrica e
tem uma tia é uma transformação completa
daquele país por causa daquela
tecnologia ou metodologia
eu não vi isso até agora eu não vi isso
acontecer até agora e ea minha crença é
que o modelo educacional e as melhorias
que a gente vai ver educacionais vãos e
incrementar mais incremental significa
você é colher
informações e ferramentas que já existem
implementar na sua a instituição na sua
escola
eu tenho aí dois anos vale do silício 15
anos com gestor educacional ensino
superior
atua em conselhos de ensino de idiomas
ensino básico tão me dedico a minha vida
bastante e educação
eu posso ir pra vocês todos os casos
onde teve sucesso
nesse período foram ligado à itv muito
mais foco e implementação e execução de
coisas já existentes do que na tentativa
de romper com o sistema completamente
isso é uma forma talvez explique um
pouco o porquê não aconteceu e porque
falta tanto acontecer ainda na educação
no brasil
eu queria citar exemplo essas empresas
aqui como exemplo de empresas que foram
incrementar de alguma forma não é um
cartão de crédito aí sim sem a filial do
banco e sem o kaká o plástico ou o o um
supermercado um e percam john martin que
implementou um sistema de controle de
inventário e super sofisticado que
permite um giro de estoque mais rápido e
com isso eu consigo ter um ganho de
escala maior ou uma experiência
transformação da experiência a de tomar
café do sabor do café da experiência da
loja ou mesmo uma clínica que vai coloca
é uma clínica popular agora acessível
para quem não tem acesso ao sus pra quem
desculpa tem dificuldade no sul não têm
acesso a plano de saúde
esses modelos incrementais são modelos
que muda o mundo até a partir de
melhorias incrementais
eu acho que a educação vai por aí também
a educação a tendência é que seja que
funciona dessa forma
daqui pra frente bom tecnologia big data
é uma realidade
eu acho que a tendência forte que a
gente vê hoje você colhe dados dos
alunos
os alunos não querem ser mais tratados
como iguais e é muito difícil que o
gestor ter resultado tá tanto alunos
como iguais e usando a mesma forma para
todo mundo então uma coisa que se fala
muito está se fazendo muito é questão de
coletar dados do aluno entender os
comportamentos demográficos como ele
aprende e a partir disso propor soluções
para desafiar mas há um desenvolvimento
ainda mais rápido ou eventualmente
remédios para ajudar o aluno naquele é
aquela
isso se chama do modelo do bea e gerando
um modelo preditivo evoluindo
prescritivo eles que a gente fala em
tecnologia
isso aqui é o que eu chamo de tecnologia
em primeiro incrementar por que ela
venha a ser acoplada na educação está
hoje mas certamente vai trazer grandes
ganhos grande sempre ganhos importantes
quer contar um pouco da história a
história de thomas edson para reforçar
tudo isso tomás edson era um aluno
inquieto nenhum aluno que a tinha
dificuldade de ficar na sala de aula e
etecétera montou um laboratório no porão
da casa dele mas não foi o cara que
descobriu a lâmpada a lata já existia
ele foi o primeiro a fazer uma série de
tentativas para fazer com que aquele
produto fosse viável comercialmente e
conseguiu depois conseguir dominar uma
parte de nova york foi um dos fundadores
da gr da general electric ficou
milionário mas foi muito mais um caso de
tentativa e erro e desenvolver em cima
daquilo que já existia
o que quero dizer pra vocês o meu ponto
hoje é o seguinte a academia tem um
papel de filosófico a gente como
acadêmica que discute a gente gosta de
cobrar falar idéias têm os profetas da
educação que dizem que daqui a cinco
anos mais uma pedra sobre pedra e
educação vai ser transformada assim como
as outras áreas mas o fato é que está no
momento em que eu diria que a gente
precisa falar menos e fazer mais
meu ponto é o despertar da educação ta
nas nossas mãos a partir de tecnologias
e ferramentas que já existem e se a
gente conseguir usar melhor as
tecnologias e ferramentas que a gente já
existe
a gente vai conseguir o resultado que a
gente tanto almeja o nosso país do mundo
como um todo
obrigado
[Aplausos]